so I was looking at this place I've got
over here and just kind of thinking
about it and thinking what should I do
with this and I realized I need
buildings buildings everywhere that's
basically how I feel about most of my
parks all the time but especially this
little Plaza I'm actually kind of afraid
I might turn it into a a City Hall most
so I should watch out with those
buildings but the first thing that I
wanted to give a try
we still built a very small building
over here just to get the heights out of
the other buildings that are next to it
but then again also kind of accentuate
that I don't know if that makes sense
but I had a couple of high buildings to
the left of this thing and I felt like I
wanted something next to it that was
very low and I liked galleries with
pillars so I decided to go with that and
it turned out to be pretty nice then
there is also the buildings around the
ship I mean the pirate ship next to this
thing of course and which is also
something that I'm going to work on in
this episode which just keeps reminding
me of the pirate ship in the efteling
because I think that's a pretty isn't it
like the biggest pirate ship in the
world or Europe something like that it's
pretty big all right and it's got
amazing scenery next to it and so
basically the idea is you have a pirate
ship
and then behind the pirate ship you have
loads of buildings and for the efteling
that would be buildings in Dutch ish
style and for this little plaza over
here I figured I would just do it in non
Dutch but like oh damn it I need to okay
that is
Alpine spook and no forget it it a weird
style that I'm currently doing and that
which I I have some mixed feelings about
actually I've got many mixed feelings
about this part because this on one hand
it turned out better than I expected so
far because it is of course a very weird
style and I don't even know where I'm
going with this entire thing it almost
feels like doodling in rollercoaster
country it's just it almost feels random
but then again it's creative to random
and you could you could say loads of
things about that but it always feels
random in a sense to me that there isn't
really one big theme or or idea that
sweeps throughout the park with many
different regions
have different looks it's all just kind
of weird and on one hand the idea of
that which is what actually got me
started on this park just to kind of do
an experiment with how this would turn
out with a theme like this has never
really been done in this way at least
but then again it did turn out partly
how I expected it to be as in it turn
out in light as kind of a Rhapsody right
now which I'm trying to get rid of and
I'm not going to judge this part too
soon because as I've experienced many
times before something may look
extremely bad and then as soon as you
place foliage it just looks awesome I
have no idea why that happens it just
seems that foliage is such an important
factor that your brain says it looks
stupid and they place one tree and then
it looks good which even accounts for
trees in front of buildings as there as
you can see with those buildings over
there they just look a lot better with a
couple of trees in front of them and
that's also something that I kind of
have mixed feelings about because on one
hand trees are awesome and they make
your party look so much better but then
again I always spam them I probably
place too many trees because there is
also such a thing as placing so many
trees that you don't see anything and
that might just be a problem as well so
I should probably when it comes to my
parks and this is also something that
I'm going to try add some more well
areas with less foliage because I'm
actually doing something that I've been
guilty of doing a while ago and I
thought I was cured of which is the fact
that I always used to spam ground
shrubbery which is something that I used
to do and then I realized that it wasn't
necessary and now I see that I'm doing
it again for this park I don't know how
that happened I just looked at it and I
saw that I did it and that just turned
out to happen like that must be my
subconscious or something like that but
it's not an issue per se for this park
because this is of course a over-the-top
park but it's definitely something I
should watch out before I shouldn't
overdo the foliage when it comes to that
and
sometimes you just need to spread it
more I feel like I'm already spreading
foliage into clusters but I should do it
even more as in some areas that have
very dense bushes and stuff like that
and some grasslands in between them that
should probably work out well but that's
definitely something to experiment with
the thing is I never really want to have
one big forests that's just trees
everywhere and especially if all those
trees are the same that makes it even
more boring because even though that
does kind of happen in real life I don't
want that because it doesn't look that
good but anyway about these buildings
I'm currently building yes they are kind
of inspired by the buildings in the
efteling as in behind the pirate ship
having that small facade but then again
they're different they're probably a lot
higher in the end and a lot bigger
while the pirate ship in front of it is
this is a lot smaller
that's strange actually I just now
noticed that the ship is almost dwarfed
by these well pretty humungous buildings
around it and once again that's the
over-the-topness and unrealistic misses
with this pike because these buildings
don't serve a function none of these
buildings actually serve a function I
was planning to have a restaurant over
here but then I realized that I already
had that restaurant near the entrance of
course so I built that restaurant next
to where's that place again I don't even
have a name for that but that small
corner with the spooky intimate blitz
and the bnm info and I suppose that's
the best place to have a restaurant
though I should probably built like a
toilet building or something like that I
should have some bathrooms and other
stuff in my Park somewhere or at least
clearly show them because when it comes
to small realistic things like that I
always forget about stuff and always get
lost in building things and then forget
about the actual important theme park
stuff but also I have a confession to
make I'm I'm kind of getting tired of
this bike I'm at the point where I'm
like especially because the themes in
this park are very similar
I'm at the point where I feel like I've
done about everything now
just rehashing things that I've already
done elsewhere in the pike right now
although sometimes with other sets and
in very different ways it does feel like
almost copying things so I really need
to move on to an ex pike and that is
very probably going to be an Asian Park
and before I do that I might do some
random episodes or actually start with
the rct3 shenanigans right away but I
kind of want to wait until I don't have
a call anymore because my voice
currently sucks and see if I can
actually do something with the Asian
theme because I have no experience with
that theme whatsoever and the usual
thing that I do when I don't have an
expert any experience with the theme is
and this is something I could recommend
to people because not really everyone
does this but it is really helpful
although it is time-consuming is I just
open up in an empty sandbox and I try to
do random things try to make random
buildings and structures using the
custom scenery sets that I've never used
for a theme that I've never done which
is something that I did for Protoss and
that turned into a huge huge project
basically the way I did that with
Protoss is I did open her an empty
sandbox and I got the sci-fi set which I
never worked with before and I just
started building and started exploring
the sci-fi sets in the live stream which
was a live stream which took many hours
and the only thing I really got was a
couple of small buildings but in the
process of that actually did learn what
kind of pieces that the sets have what
kind of sets I should use what you can
do with the various pieces and kind of
get used to the theme and the best thing
was after a couple of days of doing that
and many hours of live streaming I also
saved some of the structures I had and
that that was what would eventually turn
into the Protoss station and some of the
buildings on top of the first hill the
very small ones with the cranes on top
and I was actually able to use those
buildings right away in my rollercoaster
so it's also very nice if you really do
want to make some progress without
spending too much time on certain things
so I suppose that's really a nice tip
although like I said it is somewhat time
consuming and you do have to do
something before you start right away
because I would probably not even do
this
if I want to build a coaster and I
absolutely want to build that coaster
and nothing else I would probably also
just open a new park file and work on it
right away even if I haven't done the
theme before but for sci-fi I had no
clue what to do so I just open up that
little sandbox and kind of figured
things out which is also something where
I figured out some new pieces like these
rusty pipes from I don't know if they're
rusty but all of these random objects
from Station Jim's sci-fi set because I
didn't expect this but it turns out that
that sad actually has some pieces that
do work somewhat well with the spooky
coaster so you can use that in that but
anyway that's it for this episode so
thanks for watching and